et notre invité politique ce matin s'est
Olivier fort bonjour merci d'être avec
nous député de sa démarque premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Christelle
Bertrand du groupe La Dépêche bonjour
Christelle on joue Auriane bonjour
Olivier fort on commence évidemment
parlant de la réforme des retraites et
cette 14e journée de mobilisation hier
qui a été peu suivie à mon suivi en tout
cas depuis le début du mouvement peu de
grévise peu de manifestants et Laurent
Berger qui dit le match est en train de
se terminer est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord et est-ce que vous l'avez perdu
ce match
c'est une évidence que quand vous avez
14 journées de mobilisation 14 journées
de grève vous avez un demi salaire en
moins et l'évidence c'est que il y a
forcément une forme de démobilisation
parce qu'il y a des gens qui pour qui
pourraient d'achat n'est pas accessoire
mais l'essentiel on approche des
vacances on a des gens qui ont des
familles qui ont des enfants qui veulent
partir et donc évidemment ça pèse sur la
mobilisation maintenant est-ce que
nous avons gagné la réponse est non
puisque nous n'avons pas réussi à
obtenir le retrait cette réforme est-ce
que le gouvernement a gagné pas
davantage pourquoi tout simplement parce
que en réalité vous avez une opinion
publique qui n'a pas bougé et qui
continue à contester très fortement ce
projet et ce que je crois c'est que ça
se paiera dans les urnes et que il y a
quelque chose qui s'est incrusté enfin
qui s'est enquisté et la crise elle est
encore devant nous est-ce que ça devant
nous en France on obtient plus rien par
la grève et les manifestations ça veut
dire que vous avez aujourd'hui un
pouvoir qui est sourd à son propre
peuple et c'est extrêmement grave et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous le
dis la crise elle est devant nous il y a
quelque chose aujourd'hui on a une crise
aujourd'hui qui est une crise sociale on
a aussi une crise démocratique une crise
politique et puis il faut y ajouter
évidemment une crise climatique que
chacun mesure avec ce qui se passe en ce
moment du côté de la météo et des grands
bouleversements qui sont qui nous frappe
jour après jour et donc on a là un
pouvoir qui se refuse à toute forme de
dialogue réel avec qui que ce soit alors
même que les Français lui ont intimé
cette volonté
ça veut dire que vous avez aujourd'hui
en fait une réforme qui n'acceptait pas
personne qui n'est porté que par un seul
homme et qui pourtant va se mettre entre
en application en septembre elle était
dans mon programme lors de la campagne
présidentielle les gens ont voté pour
donc ça vaut validation quasiment il a
tort
vous savez très bien il y a 28% des
Français qui ont voté pour lui au
premier tour et encore je ne suis pas
sûr que tous est voté avec la volonté de
cette réforme
et puis tous ceux qui sont au deuxième
tour venus multiplier par deux et plus
que par deux le score du premier tour et
qui l'ont fait non pas par adhésion à
son projet mais par devoir j'ai moi-même
appelé à voter pour Emmanuel Macron en
second tour non pas par adhésion à son
projet mais simplement parce que je ne
voulais pas que Marine Le Pen devienne
présidente de la République et c'est
très différent et je me souviens que le
Président de la République lui-même
avait expliqué que il en tiendrait
compte et qu'il considérait qu'il était
obligé de celles et ceux qui venaient à
son soutien alors même qu'il ne
partageait pas ses idées je vois que le
problème avec Emmanuel Macron
je pense qu'il sait par juré et que donc
on est dans une situation où on a un
président qui sait par juré par rapport
à ses engagements entre deux tours et
qui ensuite n'en fait qu'à sa tête et
considère que l'institutions l'autorise
à écraser la volonté populaire mais la
volonté populaire elle se rappelle
toujours à vous il n'y a pas de
possibilité d'y échapper parce que la
réalité c'est que aujourd'hui vous avez
en fait un projet qui détricote le
modèle social français et ça n'est pas
le seul on a commencé avec l'assurance
chômage enfin ils ont commencé avec
l'assurance chômage vous rendez compte
qu'aujourd'hui on a des gens qui
touchent jusqu'à moins 57 % de ce qu'il
touchait auparavant on parle pas de
grands privilégiés on parle de gens qui
sont au chômage vous avez ensuite la
réforme des retraites qui vise à retirer
les deux meilleures années de retraite à
toutes celles et ceux qui ont travaillé
tôt et on travaillait dur et notamment
les femmes et puis maintenant vous avez
la réforme du RSA et puis vous avez
enfin réalité c'est que cette réforme du
RSA oui on est sur en fait on s'attaque
toujours au plus faible pendant qu'on
laisse les plus puissants à l'abri de
tous les regards mais c'est Français qui
s'inquiètent ou sagace de travailler et
de voir d'autres bénéficier de minima
sociaux sans travailler il faut parler à
cette France qui travaille mais bien sûr
il veut pas les étranges qui travaillent
mais comment est-ce qu'on lui parle on
par le salaire on lui parle l'assurance
chômage on lui parle retraite on lui
parle de ses droits on lui parle
condition de travail on lui parle refus
de l'ubérisation voilà les sujets sur
lesquels on lui parle égalisé salariale
entre les femmes et les hommes ça c'est
effectivement parler du travail et
valoriser le travail c'est une valeur
possible sur le projet de loi qui est
présenté ce matin au Conseil des
ministres mais moi je suis toujours
d'accord pour discuter simplement je
vois que il a en fait un tropisme qui
n'est pas celui auquel je peux adhérer
moi ce qui me disait demain que il veut
donner de la valeur au travail et qu'il
veut faire en sorte que les gens
désormais soient davantage reconnu dans
ce qu'ils font dans la création de
richesses pour ce pays alors évidemment
j'en saurais mais ce n'est pas ce que
j'observe ce que je vois c'est que cette
attaque toujours au plus faible et
pendant ce temps là qu'est-ce qu'on
observe rapport après rapport c'est que
les plus riches sont toujours plus
riches et qu'il paye de moins en moins
d'impôts dans ce pays c'est quand même
incroyable
vous dites ça va se payer dans les yeux
de quelle manière pour vous
tout simplement parce que je pense qu'à
un moment les Français lui diront sont
faites et je les appelle à le faire à
dire au président de la République que
il ne peut pas se considérer comme
Jupiter et d'ailleurs les Français au
mois de juin qu'est-ce qui lui ont dit
lui ont dit au premier tour bah tu as
une majorité très relative et puis au
législatives ils m'ont dit tu as une
majorité encore très relative ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire et bien que le
Président de la République était appelé
par les Français eux-mêmes à chercher à
chaque fois à concilier les points de
vue et à accepter l'idée que le débat se
fasse au Parlement mais qu'est-ce qu'on
observe l'inverse on observe un
président qui se méfie du Parlement qui
refuse le vote et demain encore je
crains malheureusement puisque tout le
monde en parle et bien que en réalité
plutôt que d'accepter l'idée que le
Parlement fasse ce pourquoi il a été
conçu donc prendre des décisions et
voter et bien on en empêche puisqu'il
n'a plus la possibilité de se présenter
lors de la prochaine présidentielle
comment est-ce qu'il peut le payer dans
les ions finalement il va peut-être y
échapper
mais il n'est pas seul et puis il y a
des élections intermédiaires il y aura
des élections qui vont intervenir dès
l'année prochaine et donc très
particulier
mais enfin je me souviens aussi que dans
tous les précédents quand un
gouvernement faisait pas tout à fait ce
qui les attendus de lui les électeurs
savaient se rappeler à son bon souvenir
je souhaite qu'il le fasse encore vous
allez continuer la mobilisation vous
tournez la page de la mobilisation vous
dites c'est terminé mais la mobilisation
elle est d'abord le fait de la date
syndicale et c'est à eux de décider des
moyens d'action je pense que Emmanuel
d'action devront évoluer forcément et
qu'on ne peut pas multiplier les jours
de grève y compris parce qu'on arrive
pendant l'été et que ça n'a pas
tellement de sens mais évolué vers quoi
sous quelle forme il dit ça sera
peut-être sous une autre forme laquelle
moi je ne sais pas ce que sera la forme
que choisiront les syndicats mais je
pense que il choisiront d'autres moyens
il y aura la possibilité à nouveau de
déposer un partager et nous avons
désormais en fait une espèce de mode
d'emploi de ce qu'il est possible de
faire ou pas puisque le Conseil
constitutionnel a rejeté plusieurs
projets de RIP en expliquant en motivant
sa décision donc en tenant compte de
cette motivation nous pouvons dans un an
redéposer un RIB et faire en sorte que
il y ait un débat celui que nous n'avons
pas eu avec les Français et un vote
tranché par les français puisque le
Président vous dit nous dit que il a été
élu cette base là on peut le vérifier
les Français eux-mêmes diront si c'était
ce qu'ils voulaient
vous vous appelez il y a LeBron Pivet
demain à ne pas utiliser l'article 40 de
la Constitution est-ce que vous avez
l'espoir d'être entendu
je fonds dans une présidente qui s'est
déjà renié en fait elle avait d'abord
dit que l'accepter la décision qui avait
été prise par la commission des finances
et puis maintenant rattrapé par le
callback par le Président de la
République qui lui dit maintenant tu
fais ce que je te demande parce que
c'est moi qui t'ai placé là et tu me
dois tout alors tu te plies et elle se
plie et moi je considère que les grands
présidents et maintenant la grande
présidente que devrait être il y avait
le brune Pivet et bien elle ne peut se
singulariser que d'une façon en étant
justement celle qui fait respecter
l'institution parlementaire et qui fait
respecter les oppositions c'est comme ça
que tous les présidents qui ont été qui
ont marqué l'histoire du Parlement ce
sont
singularisés et ils se sont singularisés
en marquant leur capacité y compris à
s'opposer à leur propre camp et leur
propre Président je me souviens d'Henri
emmanuely qui alors qu'il était proche
parmi les proches de François Mitterrand
qui avait su à certaines époques lui
dire en fait je me souviens de Philippe
Seguin je me souviens de Jean-Louis
Debré je me souviens de tous ces gens
qui à un moment ou un autre ont fait le
choix et bien de dire je ne suis pas
d'accord je ne veux pas être celui qui
brille institution parlementaire au
profit du président de la République des
pouvoirs
juste respecter la Constitution mais
vous savez très bien que sur l'article
40 il n'est jamais appliqué sur les
propositions de loi parce qu'autrement
ça tuerait d'utilisative parlementaire
ça sert à quoi de dire au parlementaire
vous avez une journée par an une petite
journée par an vous pouvez proposer
quelque chose au pays et à la et donc à
l'hémicycle justement la majorité fort
de l'expérience de la proposition de loi
Eliott voudrait durcir l'application
l'article 40 le rendre plus stricte
est-ce que ça vous paraît une bonne idée
mais vous pensez vraiment que enfin on a
vu depuis quelques mois que la
Constitution telle qu'elle est conçue
aujourd'hui et bien permet en réalité de
s'affranchir de beaucoup de choses
article 47-1 pour limiter la durée du
débat ensuite l'article 44 3 pour faire
des votes bloquées puis ensuite
l'article 49-3 pour interdire le passage
au vote maintenant l'article 40 pour
empêcher la discussion d'une proposition
de loi mais vous pensez que ça ne suffit
pas penser qu'il faut en rajouter encore
qu'il faut encore brider davantage on a
aujourd'hui une
soirée
je m'oppose aujourd'hui au fait que nous
maintenions en l'état la Cinquième
République elle a été conçue à quelle
époque elle a été conçue en 58 nous
sommes en pleine guerre d'Algérie et
d'ailleurs dans des conditions très
particulières vous vous rappelez en fait
que tout ça a commencé par un quasi coup
d'État et que c'est comme ça que le
général de Gaulle se réinstalle à l'aide
de l'État donc des conditions très
particulières qui font que le
parlementarisme rationalisé est mis en
place et trouve une justification dans
la période de crise qui était alors
vécue par les Français mais enfin on est
en paix aujourd'hui et donc vous pensez
vraiment que il est logique que un seul
homme ou une seule femme peut-être un
jour prochain et bien et tous les
pouvoirs vous rendez compte de ce que ça
veut dire y compris si demain vous avez
Marine Le Pen qui est au pouvoir ça veut
dire que même si elle n'a pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée même si les
Français sont opposés à ces projets etc
elle pourrait appliquer tout ce qu'elle
veut mais c'est un danger incroyable
comment peut-on accepter de revenir sur
même y compris tout ce qu'on se raconte
depuis toujours il faut que le pouvoir
arrête le pouvoir il faut un équilibre
des pouvoirs il faut une séparation des
pouvoirs il faut quand même que dans ce
pays on accepte l'idée de l'équilibre le
président français est de toutes les
démocraties le président qui dispose du
plus de pouvoir sans contre-pouvoir
qu'est-ce que vous ferez si demain il y
a LeBron Pivet dégâts de l'article
quarantaine est-ce que vous avez des
moyens de riposter est-ce que vous
préparez des amendements pour contourner
ça oui nous déposons des amendements de
nature différente va essayer de
contourner l'article 40 mais encore une
fois si j'étais il y a les brunes pivée
ce que je ne suis pas et bien je ferai
en sorte de faire respecter le Parlement
de faire respecter les natifs
parlementaire et puis aller au vote
pourquoi avoir peur du vote quelle est
cette démocratie dans laquelle on a peur
du vote il faut qu'à un moment donné ce
soit tranché et donc quand on a un débat
qui a divisé qui a fracturé aussi
profondément l'opinion publique il est
impératif d'aller faire trancher par le
vote est-ce que vos amendements
permettront d'aller au vote est-ce que
vous avez l'espoir d'aller au vote
demain
j'imagine que il y a aussi enfin on est
dans une dans cette république avait
très corseté donc je ne veux pas vendre
la peau de l'eau avant de l'avoir tuer
et mais j'espère qu'effectivement demain
nous aurons la possibilité d'aller
jusqu'au bout mais la meilleure façon
d'y arriver ce sera encore que quelque
part dans la journée un moment la raison
l'emporte et que de l'Elysée à Matignon
de Matignon à l'hôtel de lacet on se dis
on a une grande démocratie on aime on a
même un message à adresser non pas
seulement aux Français mais même au
monde quand vous voyez le nombre de
démocraties il libérales qui se
développe partout ailleurs et que la
France qui est ce grand pays qui a donné
la leçon démocratique a tellement de
monde va être au contraire le lieu où on
va dire bah écoutez vous nous faites la
leçon mais enfin chez vous on vote pas
non plus donc qu'est-ce que vous voulez
nous embêter les répliques bananières on
peut en avoir partout maintenant voilà
est-ce que je vous resterez jusqu'au
bout des débats où est-ce que le ciel
dégaine l'article 40 vous quitterez
comme vous avez quitté la commission je
sais pas ce qu'on fera à ce moment-là
mais enfin ce que je sais c'est que nous
allons d'abord nous battre pour faire
respecter la démocratie et vraiment ce
que je vous dis là quand je vois ce qui
se passe dans le temps de pays tant de
gens qui aujourd'hui regardent la France
le pense comme elle la pense comme un
modèle et qu'ils vont voir que en France
on peut avoir un président qui décide de
tout et qui refuse le vote assez
parlementaire je m'indigne profondément
le camp présidentiel lui dit si vous
n'êtes pas content vous n'avez qu'à
déposer une notion de censure le groupe
lutte finalement ne devrait pas la
déposer est-ce que vous le comprenez
bien sûr que je les comprends parce que
ce n'est pas la même chose vous avez
d'un côté on sait bien comment les
choses se passaient il y a il n'y a pas
de majorité parce que vous avez des gens
très différents qui votent contre la
réforme des retraites en revanche vous
avez des gens qui ne souhaitent pas
faire tomber le gouvernement chez les LR
il ne souhaite pas faire tomber le
gouvernement donc comme nous avons
besoin des voix DLR et que les LR sont
prêts pour une partie d'entre eux à
voter contre la réforme ça n'est pas le
même vote et c'est une illusion de
laisser croire qu'il y aurait une
absolue
coïncidence entre les votes sur une
sonde censure et les votes sur en fait
la réforme des retraités je vois bien je
ne sais pas ce que fera à la nu peut ne
pas décider moi en tout cas ce que je
vous dis c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
coïncidence entre le vote qui se
porterait sur la réforme des retraites
et le vote sur une zone censure et que
c'est très différent et que je vois bien
le piège tendu par le gouvernement qui
va nous faire croire que quand il n'y a
pas de vote on peut toujours voter sur
je me censure et que c'est pareil la
réponse c'est non ça n'est pas pareil
mais vous envisagez d'en déposer une ou
pas moi je n'envisage rien du tout je
pense qu'il y a un débat qu'on doit
avoir entre nous je pense que ça n'est
pas utile de donner le point au
gouvernement en laissant penser que il y
a un vote qui a été perdu et que donc
nous sommes dans une situation où il
n'existerait pas de majorité contre le
projet cette majorité elle existait
c'est même la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement ne veut pas passer
au sein de la nuque si il y a lebronfisé
utilise l'article 40 et que la PPL n'est
pas discutée dans l'hémicycle on
discutera plus d'aucun texte est-ce que
c'est une voix qui est on veut toujours
envisagée non pas d'aucun texte mais en
fait on discutera plus avec elle elle
nous propose en ce moment de venir
parler avec elle de réformer
l'institutions
la première avant de boycotter enfin
avant de boycoter avant de réformer
institutions le mieux ce serait quand
même de commencer par appliquer une
jurisprudence sur l'article 40 c'est à
dire qu'on ne l'applique pas aux
proposition de réunion sur la réforme
je ne vais pas continuer à faire le
guignol avec des gens qui me prennent
pour un con voilà donc c'est c'est pas
possible il y a un moment où il faut que
chacun prenne sa responsabilité et si on
veut vraiment que ça marche si on veut
vraiment que le parlementarisme retrouve
ces lettres de noblesse si on veut
vraiment redonner aussi un intérêt pour
la vie politique aux françaises et aux
Français alors il faut d'abord respecter
les parlementaires
l'institutions
déjà se détournent du vote se disent que
c'est un intérêt de venir voter s'il
voit qu'en fait des députés ils n'ont
même pas la possibilité de voter parce
que on vote pour nous pour qu'on vote à
leur place mais si demain on nous dit
ben écoutez vous êtes sympa vous êtes
élu mais enfin sert à quoi il y a
personne qui peut voter on va parler
européenne si vous voulez c'est une
question qui agite la nuque est-ce qu'il
y aura une liste autonome du Parti
socialiste aux européennes
on en a pas encore décidé on verra ça au
mois d'octobre puisque nous avons nous
commençons d'abord par le fond par les
idées et pour moi la seule question qui
va c'est qu'est-ce que nous portons à
l'élection européenne vous savez je suis
nous sommes des Européens convaincus
nous considérons que le niveau pertinent
pour une incidence de sujets aujourd'hui
est devenu l'Union européenne l'Union
européenne a beaucoup de défauts mais
elle a aussi une qualité c'est qu'elle
permet de prendre les sujets un niveau
qui est un sujet pour un niveau
continental et qu'elle permet
d'entraîner ensuite le reste du monde
éventuellement et donc je vois que dans
dernières années l'Europe même si c'est
une Europe qui est une Europe beaucoup
trop libérale du fait non pas de sa
nature mais parce que les dirigeants des
pays européens sont principalement
délibéraux mais je vois aussi que face
aux crises ils ont été obligés de bouger
et que sur la question de la gestion de
la crise covid sur la gestion du Green
Deal sur la gestion de la dette commune
et sur la gestion du plan
sur une liste commune parce que vous
n'avez pas beaucoup de points communs
avec la France insoumise sur la question
européenne les écologistes ils vont de
leur côté le Parti socialiste a priori
va de son côté avec qui vous pourriez
faire cette liste mais nous avons des
points communs avec tout le monde
heureusement plus avec certains qu'avec
bien sûr plus avec les écologistes c'est
une évidence qu'avec les communistes
plus exactement c'est pas je réfléchis
rien je réfléchis à tout je réfléchis
surtout au fait de savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on propose parce que dans une
élection là d'abord avant d'avoir des
candidats ou des alliances ou des listes
le premier sujet c'est de savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on propose aux Français
qu'est-ce qu'on leur dit sur la question
européenne ça dépend pas que de moi ça
dépend de ce que chacun dira vous savez
très bien que j'avais très bien que au
stade où nous en sommes et bien il y a
un point de départ c'est que nous sommes
bien plus proches des écologistes pour
ne pas dire que ce soit totalement
convergents avec eux sur certain nombre
de questions européennes et puis il y a
beaucoup plus de difficultés avec les
communistes avec mais vous pourriez vous
ranger derrière le candidat écolo en
tout cas faire une liste commune avec
les écologistes
même en 2005 sur le traité
constitutionnel européen j'observe que
nous avons nous-même réussi à dépasser à
un moment ce conflit et que la Cazeneuve
nicolas Rossignol qui a voté contre le
TCE aujourd'hui en sont des partisans
donc je vois que les choses vous en avez
parlé avec elle parce qu'elle est partie
pour une liste autonome il y a deux
candidats qui sont déjà déclarés pour
être tête de liste je ne parle pas au
nom des Verts au nom des insoumis au nom
du parti communiste je parle au nom des
socialistes et ce que je vous dis c'est
que nous avons tout simplement à tracer
notre propre voix notre propre chemin
nous verrons à ce moment-là si d'autres
sont prêts à rejoindre des positions qui
sont portées par le Parti socialiste et
ou si nous arrivons nous à nous
retrouver dans des propositions que
ferait d'autres pour formations
politiques il y a pas ça de là nous
convergerons mais il n'y a pas d'autres
possibilités que de commencer toujours
par les idées et ce que je dis de
constante ce ne sont pas les alliances
qui dictent le projet c'est le projet
qui dicte les alliances voilà et donc
vous savez aussi en juin que nous avons
négocié l'accord de la news c'était un
accord qui était très particulier ce que
nous étions dans un accord qui aurait ce
serait réalisé dans une cohabitation et
où les questions européennes
internationales étaient en réalité mise
de côté puisque c'était le domaine
partagé avec le chef de l'État et que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon très
honnêtement et très
utilement avait dit la France parlera
d'une seule voix à l'échelle européenne
à l'échelle internationale voilà donc
ces questions étaient mises de côté
elles sont maintenant devant nous et
c'est vrai que c'est le sujet le plus
difficile à gauche
ça ne signe rien du tout ça ne signe pas
l'arrêt de la nupesse pourquoi je dis ça
parce que la question européenne est une
d'abord le Scrum mode de scrutin est un
mode de suite à proportionnel donc il
n'y a qu'un seul tour et ensuite il y a
dans de toutes éternité en fait même
quand il y avait des socialistes des
communistes des écologistes qui ensemble
et bien ça n'a pas empêché d'avoir des
listes séparer aux élections européennes
et le gouvernement arrive en tête de la
gauche au sein de la news ça sera plus
le même rapport
de toute façon le rapport de force il
évolue tous les jours et ça n'est pas
les élections européennes qui maîtrisent
l'ensemble de la vie politique
hier a mis un petit coup de pression
vous avez moyennement apprécié j'ai
l'impression mais je ne pense pas que ce
soit la bonne façon de procéder je lui
ai dit donc je pense que moi je suis un
fervent partisan du rassemblement de la
gauche les écologistes je vois y compris
que la droite cherche à se rassembler
avec l'extrême droite et vous voudriez
que nous toute la gauche on se divise et
qu'on arrive
au mois de mai 2027 voilà avec 5 6 7
offres différentes mais enfin dans ces
cas-là autant dire que on arrive comme
les Bourgeois de Calais avec la corde
autour du cou et que ça sert à rien
parce que là aussi les gens sont
nombreuses Bernard Cazeneuve lance son
mouvement ce week-end en présence de
François Hollande est-ce que c'est le
début de la scission du parti socialiste
Bernard Cazeneuve a décidé de quitter le
parti socialiste donc cette façon il a
déjà fait un choix je ne crois pas qui
de scission en vue pour le Parti
socialiste mais
par une partie du Parti socialiste du
Parti socialiste Bernard Cazeneuve je ne
crois pas je crois qu'il y a des gens
qui ont un intérêt pour ce que dit la
drakazeneuve et donc il fera valoir son
point de vue il sera valoir ses idées et
puis ce sera un débat mais enfin c'est
une impasse
mais tout simplement parce que comment
moi je me souviens très bien de ce que
François Mitterrand nous a enseigné à
toutes et à tous et moins vieux que les
autres je peux vous dire que je ne l'ai
pas connu directement enfin j'en ai tiré
la leçon il a toujours dit la même chose
d'abord on rassemble son camp on
commence par ça quand vous commencez par
tirer sur votre camp par considérer que
vous êtes irré-conciable avec une partie
de la gauche et pas seulement que
l'insoumis avec les insoumis sur une
partie des sujets sur les écologistes
sur d'autres avec les communistes sur
d'autres parties mais comment est-ce que
vous voulez arriver au bout vous avez
besoin de toute façon et vous avez
besoin de nous avons besoin toute la
gauche a besoin de toute la gauche
pourquoi parce que aucun parti n'est
capable de se qualifier seul au retour
d'une élection présidentielle de se
qualifier seul au second tour d'élection
législatives et donc vous avez besoin
d'être union vous avez besoin d'avancer
ensemble et c'est peut-être même la
meilleure solution ça veut dire qu'il
faut tenir compte de tout le monde parce
que quand vous êtes finalement à penser
que vous êtes hégémonique la réalité
c'est que pour gouverner vous avez
besoin d'un assise large si vous voulez
transformer ce pays vous avez besoin
d'une assise qui soit la plus large
possible vous ne pouvez pas gouverner
avec 15 20 25 % des Français vous avez
besoin de trouver des majorités et donc
ça suppose en permanence de nouer des
compromis ça n'est pas un gros mot et ce
compromis il doit être noué avec
l'ensemble de la gauche
qu'on va trouver une majorité que la
gauche va trouver une majorité mais nous
avons quel va rassembler l'ensemble des
Français et comment pensez-vous enfin
il y a des moments où les bras me
tombent en fait le Parti socialiste a
fait à l'élection présidentielle
1,7%. Jean-Luc Mélenchon a fait 22% et
on pense que en fait Jean-Luc Mélenchon
est un problème et donc que nous ne
devons pas lui parler et que en partant
de 1,7 on arrivera nous à 30% au premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle je dis
que il y a là quand même quelque chose
qui est une une faute contre l'esprit
quoi en fait il y a un moment où il faut
quand même se rendre à l'évidence nous
avons besoin de tout le monde je ne dis
pas que le rapport de force n'a pas déjà
évolué il a déjà évolué et les élections
présidentielles c'est les élections
présidentielles et qui a les questions
de l'Incarnation qui pèsent aussi mais
enfin je sais aussi que il y a des
rapports de force et que aucun parti à
gauche n'étant de mesure seul de se
qualifier et que moi je ne suis pas là
simplement pour me demander si je vais
être un point devant ou un point
derrière mon voisin le plus immédiat je
suis là pour me demander comment est-ce
qu'on fait pour faire faire gagner la
gauche et c'est ça qui est important
parce que tout ce qu'on vient d'évoquer
dans la première partie de l'émission
donc toutes les questions qui sont qui
sont maintenant sur la table sur
l'assurance chômage sur les retraites
sur le RSA demain sur l'immigration etc
mais vous pensez que les gens qui ont
besoin de nous ils ont 30 ans à attendre
que la gauche veuille bien enfin se
rassembler pour pouvoir réussir non ils
ont besoin de nous maintenant notre
responsabilité c'est maintenant et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait si demain matin
c'est Marine Le Pen j'arrive au pouvoir
on dira bah on avait nous tous notre
temps on considérait que c'était encore
possible d'attendre non on n'a pas de
temps c'est l'urgence et donc quand
c'est l'urgence on prend les moyens
nécessaires et on fait en sorte de se
concilier traditionnellement un candidat
d'élection présidentielle incarne un peu
l'épicentre de son camp est-ce que c'est
pas le problème de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
aujourd'hui il n'incarne pas ça et la
gauche est un peu se trouve un peu
déséquilibrée
c'est à Jean-Luc Mélenchon de se poser
cette question ce n'est pas à moi moi je
considère que il y a aujourd'hui une
offre qui doit redevenir centrale c'est
celle que porte socialiste c'est normal
je suis socialiste je comprends très
bien que les écologistes tu avais que
les écologistes que les communistes sur
les communistes les insoumis avec les
insoumis la réalité c'est que il faut
incarner l'ensemble pour réussir on ne
peut pas partir du moment où on veut
incarner en fait un rassemblement large
d'abord de la gauche puis des Français
de votre partie le week-end dernier à
Montpellier il y avait une réunion de
l’autrelle du Parti socialiste fondation
menée par Nicolas maire rossignols
delgane vous avez été invité vous ne
vous y êtes pas rendu et Nicolas Maher
Rossignol a dit le premier secrétaire ne
devrait pas être le premier secteur
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça non
mais enfin franchement je pense que il y
a des gens qui se font mal tout seul
donc il faut arrêter avec ce type de de
propos qui honorent pas ce qu'il les
préfèrent et qui relève la sortie de
route donc il faut rester mais tout
simplement parce que je considère que
c'était pas ma place ce jour-là et que
je suis pas le chef d'un courant je suis
le chef d'un parti politique et donc je
veux travailler avec celles et ceux qui
veulent travailler en bon intelligence
avec la majorité et que quand c'est
uniquement pour expliquer que on est
contre tout ce que fait la direction je
vois pas trop l'intérêt en fait donc ça
n'empêche pas que tous les jours je
cherche sur les dossiers de fond sur le
RSA d'en dire un détail un soir nous
avons nous sommes parvenus à l'unanimité
à une position nous parvenons toutes les
semaines sur tous les sujets de fond à
avancer et donc après il y a la
politique politicienne mais ça c'est un
registre que j'essaye d'abandonner
complètement parce que quand on est dans
ce registre là en général on ne parle
pas aux Français on ne se parle qu'à
nous-mêmes et je crois que socialistes
sont déjà montrés par le passé qu'il
savait beaucoup se regarder le nombril
mais quand tu regardes le nombril et
bien personne ne les regarde et moi je
veux que on regarde à nouveau ce que dit
le Parti socialiste merci Olivier fort
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
la Une de La Dépêche c'est l'Ukraine
l'explosion qui peut tout changer cette
année de votre journal merci Christelle
merci j'ai fait on passe au club de
territoire